What seemed to me to, to resonate, uh,
around you with folks that I did not expect visit,
you really never seem to dislike anybody on the campaign trail.
You didn't dislike people who didn't agree with you.
You didn't dislike people who insulted you,
you didn't dislike the people you were running against. You spoke, um,
fondly and with a lot of empathy, um, of, towards people on the other side,
the way you framed your, your, your policies had that dimension.
You're talking about the Bernie Sanders and imagining yourself to the left of
him. But one way people experienced politics is interesting ideological.
It's also on this axis of confrontational newness
and you a pretty, um, distinctive like left policy agenda,
but on the confrontational access, you were way down, right?
You would talk to people.
Democrats would rarely talk to go on programs that would rarely go on.
And even now on Twitter, I think you very,
self-consciously cultivate a very nice persona in a very nice space.
And I'd like to hear a bit about how you think about that,
because whether it was all authentic,
I think there's at least some recognition that it has power now.
And given that it's a pretty basic thing.
I think it probably had more power than you would have expected,
or certainly than I would've expected.
Wow. I hadn't thought of it. And in those terms,
but I mean, you've known me for a while. So you know that, um,
the nice thing is a complete facade
that I'm actually naturally very bitter. Um, now it's,
it's the case that I like most Americans.
And then I think that there've been massive problems that have been built up
over decades and decades.
And you wrote a book on polarization and why we're polarized.
And I feel like people have gotten driven into different corners and pitted
against each other in a way that's unproductive.
I naturally don't get angry at people that disagree with me.
I kind of expected degree of political, uh, asynchrony, because,
you know, it's like not like someone's going to believe everything you believe.
And one of the things that I did find running for president was that
the media would often try and go to me into conflicts.
It would be like, this person said this, what do you think about that? And,
and the dynamic was supposed to foment and expression of outrage.
And then I would say something that seemed to me to be like the natural
reaction,
but I just think that the outrage cycle is very,
very negative. Uh, and I think a lot of Americans,
including me are very tired of it, but I can genuinely say it.
Wasn't really a strategy on my part. And it's not a strategy now,
except in so far as when I'm putting out a message,
I just find it more productive for me to be positive
than for me to throw a rock at somebody.
It struck me too, that it reflected in part the media you came up through.
So I think when most run for president, they think about getting coverage on,
you know, MSNBC and in democratic or liberal aligned
publications, which have,
which tend to reward and more confrontational approach.
And that's true also for centrist publications, right? You, you,
you have a great story on your blog about being at an early Iowa event.
And like all the reporters are there to hear Michael Abinadi,
including like the centrist reporters who just want conflict, but you came up,
I mean, you're on my, on this podcast pretty early in your campaign,
but you did Joe Rogan's podcast, my friend, Sam Harris, um,
you were on like a lot of YouTube world things, and that's a, that's a,
it's a very political space. And sometimes it can be even an angry space,
but it's, it's like a more mixed space.
You have like a lot of fans on Reddit and four Chan. And that struck me as,
uh, like informing your approach way through that,
that those are different worlds to talk to where people have different political
concerns.
And it always struck me that you ended up representing a slightly less polarized
media in what ended up working for you and what you then
were rewarded for saying, and, and representing and politics.
Israel. I genuinely went where they would have me,
I guess, where like the, the, uh,
MSNBC's and CNN's, um, uh, and, you know, central,
his publications were not very excited to have me on, frankly.
So if you were me and you were like, who wants to talk to me? Like, Hey,
do you want to talk to me?
That's one reason I'm grateful to you because you had me on when others were
not. And so I'm grateful to you, and I've always seen you as a very,
very smart fact-driven purveyor of what
you regard as truth, you know, and, and it's, you know,
it's one reason I appreciate you and this conversation so much,
and I did not get that vibe
from some other outlets and journalists. And so, you know,
it really wasn't necessity being the mother of invention,
where I would talk to people that would have me on, um,
and a lot of those folks where you tubers and,
and podcasters and folks who didn't have a cable network behind them.
Yeah. It's a, and it worked, I mean, I want to get to UBI,
so we won't spend all, all the time looking retrospective of your campaign, but,
but it did just strike me as I thought,
you and Pete Buddha judge did the best job of this.
And you did somewhat differently. Right?
I don't think people would have judge would have gone on Ben Shapiro show and,
and, and debated circumcision like that wasn't his vibe, but there was, uh,
like Joe Biden for his virtues has a very old media view
of politics. And also doesn't do that much media.
And a lot of Democrats would come up through, through the ranks for a long time.
Like they saw media very much. I would call it the way it wasn't 2005,
and now there's this burbling fractured and it can be very polarized,
but it also can be very mixed up in a way that can be useful world out there.
And that if you're a lot of it,
much more audience than people, um, I think in the mainstream media recognize,
you know,
what some of these folks on YouTube were able to command is in the millions. It,
um, it, it, it rivals the cable networks,
but it doesn't have like the mainstream establishment, uh,
respect that say a cable network does. And so it gets ignored,
but it's no worse a way to reach people.
And I think Reddit had that quality for you too. You're very big on routers,
just aren't ready yesterday. And you're involved, I guess,
in some California data privacy initiative and had 23,000 up votes,
just noting that you were part of it. So these are,
these are pretty different worlds. And, and,
and I wonder how much you think the democratic party or just traditional
politics,
politicians in general are missing them and leaving these worlds unspoken too.
Well. This to me is, um, something we should talk about more as well,
because I think the shifting media landscape is going to impact
politics very dramatically. And some folks are going to be late to it.
Like you're on top of it, just from that line of questioning.
But if you look at the cable news audiences, um,
you're looking at the low millions and it tends to be like the same 2 million
people over and over again. And you're talking about a massive population of,
you know, tens of millions of voters.
And so you hit it on the head where if you look at the audience of some of the
biggest podcasts, uh, it goes into the millions.
It is higher than the cable news casts.
And they cable newscasts drive this media narrative bubble that
then gets self-reinforcing. And then everyone looks out out and says like, Hey,
aren't you concerned about whatever the heck we were concerned about yesterday.
And meanwhile, like, they're just listening to Joe Rogan or whomever, you know,
like that they, they're getting a very different perspective.
And they're hearing about issues that are more relevant to them than a
lot of the DC oriented issues.
The biggest example of that on the trail was impeachment.
I don't think I got a single question about impeachment, uh, the entire time.
And then, and this was when he was actually getting impeached.
So there are different conversations happening,
and it would be very beneficial for politicians generally,
but Democrats in particular to start trying to broaden their universe,
because what you don't want to do is just end up in a world where just talking
to each other and then wondering why no,
one's listening to you and that's the danger.
And one of the things that I like about these different worlds as somebody who I
try to spend a certain amount of my media diet in subcultures that are not my
main one, um,
because I think it's important to know how their argumentative universe is work
and what they consider important and unimportant.
And this to me was always the secret of your campaign that people didn't quite
realize, uh, that politics,
Washington politics has developed a set of things that it considers like the
questions of the day, the week, the month, a year. Um, so, you know,
at a certain point it's impeachment, which is very, very,
it was important that like I ran an impeachment podcast and I think it's
important what was happening there. Um, but taxes, healthcare, I mean,
these are, these are real things you might ask, like, how did this guy,
Andrew Yang get on Joe Rogan and some of these other shows because he doesn't
allow just anybody on, um, that's a big show.
He has a lot of options about who comes on and there's this whole world that is
very focused on AI risk and what that's going to do and how that's going to
change things.
And when you came up and wanted to move that up as an issue in politics increase
like as a political scientist would say, increase in salience and politics,
there was a,
a world of people there for that because they were already having that
conversation. But nobody in politics was like politics reflected. The,
the set of issues at Washington thought was important and understood how to talk
about, but it's not the only set of issues people care about.
And so then there are these whole worlds that are really underserved in terms of
their concerns.
And like what always struck me as an interesting bypass you took into this
was like the value of your campaign to me, was it, it,
it elevated concerns that deserve more attention to politics,
and they typically get not just solutions, but concerns. And you know,
that I have a different view on a lot of the AI economic risks than you do,
or at least somewhat. But, um,
but there's no doubt that it should be talked about.
And so you went where people were talking about it.
And I think there was a lot of surprise that so many people were so, uh,
were so concerned and so engaged on this.
And so ready for a candidate to try to say, no,
this should be one of the 10 issues we talk about. Like,
let's move something else out of the frame.
Yeah, that's right. As well. Where if you talk to techies,
they're much more concerned about AI. And as you know,
the central argument of why campaign around automation than a lot of other
Americans,
and they were happy to talk to a political figure who was talking about
something that they'd been thinking about for months or years.
And one of the funny byproducts of it all was that I ended up having
conversations with people that didn't feel terribly political.
If you know what I mean, it was like, look like what's going on with AI? Like,
what should we be concerned about? Like what,
what does that competitive landscape with China look like over time? Uh,
and because of that,
I ended up reaching audiences that genuinely did not consider themselves super
political.
And hopefully I did broaden the range of concerns that we should be looking at
as a country. And it wasn't very deliberate on my part. I mean,
I just cared about what I cared about,
what the folks who also cared about it,
but it is a sign how both DC and the media have this
relationship where there's like a set of prescribed concerns that may or may not
line up with the concerns around the country. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.